[Music]
foreign
skin
what color would you say that is
my color
oh says they have the worst land
possible
but they outsmart everybody the land had
oil on it
Black Gold
money flows freely here now dude love
that money sir
this wealth should come to us
their time is over
it's going to be another tragedy
when this money started coming
we should have known it came with
something else
they're like buzzards circling our
people
we're still Warriors
[Applause]
[Music]
kill these white men who killed my
family
I need you here I am right here
[Applause]
you've got to take back control of your
home
[Applause]
I was uh sent down from Washington DC to
see about these murders
see what about him
see who's doing it
[Applause]
[Music]
expect in America to make all this go
away
[Music]
you know they don't happen anymore
this is a National Emergency
didn't need a charge
[Music]
we're in a race against the Nazis
and I know what it means
if the Nazis have a bomb
we have a 12-month Head Start 18. how
could you possibly know that
we've got one hope
all America's industrial night at
scientific innovation connected here
secret Laboratory
keep everyone there until it's done
let's go recruit some scientists
build a town build it fast
we don't let scientists ring their
families will never get the best
why would we go to the middle of no
no why why how about because this is the
most important thing that ever happened
in the history of the world
you're the great improviser but this
you can't do in your head
are we saying there's a chance that when
we push that button we destroy the world
chances are near zero
near zero what do you want for Theory
alone zero would be nice
[Music]
this is a matter of life and death
but I can perform this miracle
World War II would be over our boys
would come home
that's happening isn't it
world
but remember this day
I work here
will ensure peace mankind has never seen
[Music]
until somebody builds a bigger one
you are the man who gave them the power
to destroy themselves
and the world is not prepared
foreign
who do you think the best driver is
probably Rory I would dust him in a lap
video games with some crazy dreams of
racing cars Doug you're the one that
told us always do something we love
cars cost
look around it's not our world son
what is this it's a contest
the best Gran Turismo players in the
world
get a chance to compete in professional
racing dude this is real
[Applause]
I'm sorry I really think you're gonna
take a kid who plays video games in
their bedroom you're gonna strap them to
a 200 mile an hour rocket it'll tear
them to pieces
you can hate me now it's not gonna work
the guys who race are Elite athletes but
I won't stop now your kids are scrawny
little gamer kids well that's why you
coming come on let's go
must be a new experience for you moving
your legs
you're puked on my lawn there's no
turning back man when you're in a race
the cockpit is gonna be 140 degrees
Fahrenheit
g-forces will be twice when an astronaut
experiences upon liftoff I can't see
anything
hey you get extra points for that in the
game Jesus Christ
this whole thing is insane but out of
the Couchsurfing nerds that you sent me
he is the best one he made it
welcome to Team Nissan
[Music]
of the game it's called racing
if you missed the line in the game you
reset you miss it on the track
you could die
I know this track man I've raced it a
thousand times
that's what I'm talking about
holy
I will tell you I've never seen anything
like it holy
is the craziest I think I've ever seen
everything okay
the Ferrari oh language the baby's here
yo what up everybody Roy and kitty here
I'm gonna pick a stock and talk about
why I think it's interesting and that
stock is Gamestop I love this guy
retail Traders I hooked into GameStop I
think they think it's a good investment
it looks like there's one guy driving
all the buying who is this
the money man happy to take it
Wall Street is betting that this company
is gonna fail if it fails these hedge
fund people make a ton of money
70 000 people have watched this video
[Music]
if he's in I'm in if he's in I'm in
GameStop those shares not stopping don't
stop it's only gonna go up when they hit
I'm gonna buy you a mansion drink today
my brother is a nerd Wall Street must be
seen this right you should probably dial
in holy do you have a minute I uh
um
babe how much did we make today
how much did we lose today a billion and
yesterday
four million and yesterday a billion
yeah
really really rich
you got rich dudes pissing in their
pants right now they're coming after you
we need to talk about the Game Stop
situation
retail Traders always lose you've been
served Wall Street cheated surprise
surprise you have to testify before
Congress the
[Music]
they're gonna win
what's the point in one of the race if
you let some idiot still the prize a lot
of people feel the system is broken the
whole idea of the stock market is if
you're smart and maybe with a little
luck you can make your fortune certainly
not anymore
there's no hope for the little guy
balls
maybe now there is yeah
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
from the beginning
people coming together
[Music]
[Applause]
you know you're a superstar
I'm a superstar
[Applause]
the music and the message
peace oh life is worth much more
Bob they try to kill you and your wife
and now you're choosing to return to
Jamaica to play a peace concert
don't you fear for your life
[Music]
my life is not important to me oh you
satisfied
my life is for people
do you really think this world will make
it
yes
there's nowhere to eat
that's the source of your strength
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
destiny
no doubt you've seen the chaos in the
streets
we must make an example our France will
fall
what would you do with this assignment
of defense was transferred to you
[Applause]
I promise you probably had successes
everyone
around is
this is my uniform
and that defense Victory too long
what is your name Napoleon
the course of my life is changing
I'm destined for greatness
for those in power will only see me as a
sword
I suggest you take the throne as a king
shall we vote
[Applause]
and his lack of simple good manners
you think you're great
this is
melting forces against me what's the
outcome of this you don't succeed
Your Majesty we are discovered good
I'm the first to admit when I make a
mistake
I simply never do
the city is for some glamorous
stimulating prosperous
only recently has it become dangerous
[Music]
Jack I think I found something three
women were strangled over the last two
weeks you're on the lifestyle desk
you're not covering a homicide I think
the murders are connected
strangled just came over the wire I'm
killing the follow-up you don't have a
story how many women have to die before
it's a story
[Music]
you start talking never seen him this
tight-lipped about anything I don't care
if it's one killer or four we're gonna
catch whoever did this
Boston police hands on the wall we had
them we just let them walk away
everything lines up with them his
history the progression of the crimes
everything you know how many people have
gone down the rabbit hole with
it's a dead end every time with this
case
find out there
when is this gonna stop Loretta I need
you to call in a favor
be quick
I don't want to get fired tonight any
lawyer worth a dime would pick this
apart
you really want to use this paper to
tear down the police department if
anyone else was blowing it this badly
we'd have put it on the front page a
long time ago and he used to take down
an address if I don't call back in an
hour give it to the police Loretta
there's more than one lunatic out there
and you're going to get us both killed
the world is just delusion
these guys put their lives online
every single day
we sleep good at night because these
guys deal with the Uglies
where you hit how are we gonna get out
of here
Monday's for sure
you don't come out the same way you went
in
Sea United States two suspects president
possession of God
you're looking at life for killing a cop
so we need to connect we've got a tip
from a confidential informant about a
stash we got suspicious you didn't
notify him of the warrant
just one of those things
about yourself
remember that money house I told you all
about
I'm gonna need your help
I get a million bucks do you hear what
you're asking me to do
you can't do this without you
he's an informative
yeah I don't think I could do this bro
you better do it
probably gonna explain this
you made me miss my Yankees game so what
do you got two metals Game Pass
across the victim's door they know
exactly where the money is they don't
kill anyone
you figure they were cops here
I've been having nightmares what if
somebody finds out
is Tommy taking money on the side
never
got a dead cop a Euro partner and a
widow this investigation is over my gut
is right on this song all you got is
conjecture
[Music]
you're about an inch away from getting
bounced out of the IAB it's our job that
the community uphold the law sometimes
you got to do a smaller arm
a big right
1984 has been a tough year our sales are
down our growth is down sunny I rushed
you in here to grow the basketball
business
people don't know what the hell a Nike
is what's a Converse NBA All-Star shoes
there's nothing cool about Nike you
would have to have a pretty compelling
pitch I can tell them the one thing the
other companies can't compete with
our basketball Division is terrible I do
not love it
this is where you come up with a
brilliant idea that no one else can see
let's hear it
I got it I found him who's that Jesus
can't afford it I'm willing to bet my
career on one guy
my name is Sonny Vaccaro I'm with Nike
you typically make it a habit of showing
up at people's front doors unannounced I
don't like to take no for an answer oh
man here we go you asked me what I do
here this is what I do I find you
players and I feel it this time okay
it's risky when you were selling
sneakers out of the back of your
Plymouth that was risky don't change
that now for a rookie yes who's never
set foot on an NBA court that's the
literal definition of rookie yeah
what's the plan we build a shoe line
around just him
I need the greatest basketball shoe
that's ever been made who's the player
Michael Jordan
[Music]
have our attention
I believe he's the future and his story
is gonna make us want to fly but the
shoe is just a ship until my son steps
into it
[Music]
got a name for it
Air Jordan
seriously maybe it'll grow on me
[Music]
the streets are getting covered in body
parts and we're sitting on our hands how
many dead 20. I need you Israel needs
you
with every bomb a message is sent to our
people each time to send a message of
our own
[Music]
I want you to find out who did this to
my daughter and I want them dead no one
asking over there I ghosts
guys something is happening
tell me what you're doing here Avi right
outside Gaza with the U.S senator
all hands on decks
teaching them how to make bombs the
bombs may be sophisticated but there's
no strategy in these attacks we need to
think like Mad Men
yeah yeah
sorry was that the engineer yeah don't
scare me I'm not trying to scare you I'm
trying to prepare you I'm already
prepared to die we'll see about that
[Music]
this is all our fun brother
we gotta find a way into that house
who's the engineer he's here
[Applause]
I need a visual before you disappeared
[Music]
[Applause]
it was the most beautiful thing I'd ever
seen
I played for five minutes
still see falling blocks in my dreams
it's poetry art and math all working in
magical synchronicities
it's the perfect game Tetris Tetris
Tetris Tetris Tetris I don't get it
It's a combination of tetra Greek for
four and tennis tennis the Russian
inventor he likes tennis Hazel yeah this
game isn't just addictive it stays with
you this is a once in a lifetime
opportunity hey only 10 other people in
the world have seen what you're about to
see
it's called The Game Boy packaging with
Tetris can you give us the rights
Soviet Union had worldwide rights
nothing gets out easily I'm gonna go to
Moscow you're walking into a country
there's still considers America enemy
Numero Uno okie dokie sure you don't
have to talk to your wife about this
first pioneers have to bet the house to
win but not literally listen
have you ever heard our apartment this
quiet before
this is the inventor of Tetris your game
is brilliant I'm Gonna Make You A
Millionaire Mr Hodges have you ever
negotiated with the Soviets
we're here for Tetris
what do you say I don't speak Russian
s
started watching you and your family do
you know where your husband is what the
hell is going on the world is changing
and Soviet Union will not be left behind
you want to play with the big boys this
is how the world Works where is this is
insane we can't protect you sometimes
you gotta forget to
again
this is Criminal
Soviet Union is about to implode
Cavalry is coming we don't have time not
have a plan
come on you guys are the kings of
Cliffhangers
[Music]
do you know what the greatest thing
about America is you can make things
happen here like nowhere else
you have the power to create your own
future if you can be anything you can do
anything
you want to sell high-end stuffed
Himalayan cats under stuffed actually
for greater posability we're
professionals we're giving the people
what they need
[Music]
the latest members we broke the entire
internet thing
or you go home
[Music]
Ty would tell you he did it all
which is as crazy as believing the
stuffed animals are gold
do you see the truck crash
poor beanies
this has always been my company company
we created together you have to be so
dramatic I mean my salary's been reduced
75 yeah I'm just doing what's necessary
you know running the real actual
business over here
[Music]
my life is this company can I see where
it's going
there are signs of real trouble genius
is one percent inspiration 99
presentation
that's not how the saying goes
everything good that's happened to me is
because if you guys we are bonded
forever
you're poisoning him
countless times
[Music]
I have our perfect Partners lined up
Jehovah's Witnesses the greatest
one-on-one salesman in the world how
brilliant is that
I'm gonna go
[Music]
I only want to speak to Oprah Winfrey
has she reached out
we all write our own stories serious
Richard I'd like to speak to him
[Applause]
this time that's mean the metal metal Mr
Richard Montagne I'm the guy who helped
bring the world the most popular snack
it's ever seen are you ready
I will I've been ready all right all
right it was a little bit more like this
[Music]
before I got here dear God please
forgive me for the gang the drugs it's
going cars what the heck man let's move
it hey he's pranking now go ahead baby
the guy started at the berry bottom I
know I don't look it but I got a PhD I'm
poor hungry and determined sir okay I
can see you're gonna be a weird one
what's happening well son Frito-Lay
isn't getting enough orders to keep the
Factory open oh he's a cool ranch anyway
[Applause]
that lady
what is it it burns stop eating it I
like it it was good I had been searching
for an answer
and there it was
they had been there the entire time
you got an idea it's a spicy kid it's
gonna change everything it will save our
Factory and you're a janitor we're gonna
go hang on
figure out the next step see the
Hispanic market will not be ignored
Hispanic market will not be ignored good
but in your voice
is you're wasting time and the janitor
is crazy idea guys like you want me
we'll get shots like this you see that
guy right there I see a chingon Montana
yes
[Music]
and be great
we want to know that we matter to you if
we know that there was a product out
there for us we'd say take our money
I got a little Hood there at the end but
[Applause]
[Music]
look you've had a good career
I don't think you're a big bad Master
spy
[Music]
I think you just
messed up
I think you might have been angry at
what's going on the Russians attacked
our democracy for the election time
reality
were you surprised to see us today
is my partner what partner Wally Taylor
hey how are you
we have a search warrant for your house
oh my goodness okay
would you like to see it yes please
125 pounds you guys flatter me
let's probably have a sense of humor
that was on your driver's license that's
right
reality what if I said that you printed
out classified information
that document was made its way outside
of NSA
and the most likely candidate
is you
I think you know a lot more than what
you're telling us at this point
I'm trying to deploy I'm not trying to
be a whistleblower that's crazy
now why I'm here is to figure out the
why behind this look over here
reality reality reality
was there something that just
pushed you over the edge on this
foreign
no Esther I'm picking up your trash
because I don't work here
don't forget you have a dermatologist
appointment today also came to deposit
loans disability check growing up I was
told my parents were special when I got
old enough I realized that's the word
adults use when someone has a disability
who's that he looks thirsty look at her
the part of her brain that makes your
hornies still work she just wants to
give him something to drink the source
that could help them
[Music]
care of a child what choice do we have
my mother named me after her favorite
cartoon character
now you know what B is short for but hey
at least we were happy
I know Bee's childhood was somewhat
non-traditional I don't want to do this
anymore you said it'll be fun and it's
not fun you gotta learn how to drive I'm
10. if that hasn't stopped her from
enjoying it well everyone was busy
worrying about my future B still waiting
on those college applications I know I
was just trying to balance work school
and caring for my parents is that why
you never want me to come over no it's
okay everyone's embarrassed by the
parents
hi come on in man with your grades and
extracurriculars you have a shot of
getting into any college I can't you can
no I mean I can't leave
my whole life I've been torn between
wanting to get away from my parents
and wanting to care for them
because you
do you convince yourself that they're
helpless
we spent a very long time worrying about
other people I think it's time to focus
on you for a while
we are our family but one of these days
you're gonna move out and get married
and that's what kids are supposed to do
a whole new world with an unknown future
shoot for the stars you'll hit the roof
kind of a messed up saying
my name is Sharon and I'm an alcoholic
for this wooden headache
advice
find a reason to be here that's bigger
than you are I read about this family in
the paper I think this is it
we have a situation and we all look
pretty for mommy well maybe just a
little off the cheeks
God is here with us right now
and we are here with you something about
that little girl without a mom sick my
family's LED dry from all the hospital
bills I think I'm supposed to help hi
Sharon yes ma'am I just wanted to come
by and give you this I just made dinner
if you want to stay would love to
what are you doing I met this woman
this perfect she'll fit right in 400
000 Plus in medical bills all three
credit cards maxed out your income's
only 3 600 a month yes ma'am that's not
good ad no ma'am I'm gonna put together
a press kit for a corporate donations
that kind of thing
smile
girls help your daddy out
I've owned four small businesses I'm
good at plenty of things taking No for
an answering one of them Daddy's in the
first head they're asking us to reduce
the family's medical bills due to
hardship no I'm asking you to erase them
all of them
was that funny
[Applause]
[Music]
horse oh you want to go on an adventure
we'll need to fly 700 miles to the
Children's Hospital you're telling me we
need a plane now how exactly do you
recommend we get a plane doc okay to
your plane I promise
so we are going to save this girl you
hear me we're gonna need a lot of
shovels
this is our last chance if we don't take
it Michelle dies
[Music]
how did it become your responsibility to
save her because I'm here because I can
[Music]
all right
[Applause]
[Music]
what about boys at school must be some
handsome ones
[Applause]
[Music]
hey Square I am not a square I think we
should invite Greg this weekend what's
this weekend
these people are hippies Rebels against
old-fashioned Authority I think these
kids need help the need is a bear you're
passing judgment on people you know
nothing about maybe that's why your
church is so empty when God walks in
here brings me a hippie I'll ask him
what it's all about
because I do not understand
this house has a very good vibe
[Applause]
[Music]
there is an Empire
I want to reach my people you need to
speak to them in a language they
understand before I bring them in I'm
gonna lose my job we can only walk
through doors open to us in your church
that's a door that shut
you've probably noticed we have some
guests here today I'd like you to meet
my new friends welcome
they don't belong here half of Money
wearing shoes they're staining the new
shag carpet they need our help
if you feel like you're misunderstood
and judged you will find forgiveness and
freedom right here that was awesome
Collette door is open any time of day
and if there are some who don't like
that well then that door works both ways
all right Pastor let's begin I was
almost done with this but then you did
what nobody else but even dared
this thing that we found I feel like I
belong you're gonna need a bigger Church
the country is a dark and divided place
but now there's hope and it's spreading
this is your home and I want you to tell
all your friends about it
[Music]
it's known as the beautiful game but
let's face it it's a complicated game
guys soccer as you like to call it is
like life next season I think we have a
real shot
I'm sorry uh Thomas did nobody tell you
you're you're fired good news is you got
two options option one that's where
you're currently at or American Samoa
are you serious all alone
we haven't scored one goal in the
history of our country trying to have a
soccer team go
let's start again humiliation mark my
words things are going to change I got
us a new coach
something to drink whiskey beer wine yep
we got all those which one whiskey beer
and one
it's safe to say you have zero Talent OR
understanding of the game
right about the sky what he is white
coach you got the toughest job on the
island
what we want is just one goal one goal
come on guys we've worked too long and
hard for this you've only been here a
few days
thank you
I can't work with these guys for them
it's like some sort of game
it is a game Palace
that's it giant leadership now we're
making some progress
thank you for sending us Mr rongan we've
become quite attached to him like
finding a little lost white kid at the
mall and telling him which way to go
how long's the flight daddy you start
taking the nap on the runway when you
wake up we'll be back home in Louisiana
[Music]
96 bravo bravo into the pattern on left
downwind
[Music]
sacrificing your Easter Sunday just to
fly us home you're welcome to ride up
front looks like the space shuttle got
Moon between the taxi
turn your headset you can listen to me
talk to air traffic control from your
traffic insight
are you scaring with your feet yep
aren't you supposed to repeat back what
he just
Joe
Miami Center anyone there say your tail
number intention Doug what's going on
I've got an emergency up here my wife
and daughters are on this plane
I need to stop a plane crash you're the
only person I know I can save them has
he flown to King Air never
got a very tight window how long has it
been in the air
easing off of those controls can you do
that we got a real good co-pilot head up
here landing gear down I got it I'm
looking for them
no doubt we're gonna need it
[Music]
back there he's flying right toward the
storms
I love you girl you can do it sometimes
you gotta trust me things you can't see
[Music]
thank you